you know i often tell guys like um you
have to be careful
who you listen to out there and who you
take advice from it and a couple of
things i always ask them you know look
at is would you trade places with that
person number one number two
somebody can only take you as far as
they've come right so if you're i mean
if you're listening to some guy that has
the same upload button that i do that
you do that gammon does that rola does
for example that really haven't come
very far in the life and have done
nothing
should you be listening to them so i
mean like
how do you generally vet for information
sources like what do you do to
ensure that you really want to listen to
this person like i mean how did you
decide to listen to me like why would
you say well i'm gonna listen to this
bald bearded guy up in canada that's
talking about this that and the other
thing because my friend gammon
recommended it like why did you decide
to do that
well because i trust gammon
right i mean he and i he um he shares an
office building with me okay
and i i i we're just in texas together
you know and and our whole thing is
my new little program that you came on
was sex money power
because we all want you know when i was
in high school i wanted sex to my money
i wanted power and they don't teach that
in school
so that's that's why i listen to george
listen to guys like you and all this
and then exactly as you guys say the
testosterone level's going down
and the women are getting desperate
uh
and i i laughed because i had nicola dr
nicole on to talk to you and
rallo
because she's the woman going up you
know she went through a epiphany she
says i better do something myself so
she's a rich young woman yeah and i meet
a lot of these rich young women but they
all hate you and ralla
they don't hate us what they what they
don't like is the message that we
provide because it doesn't necessarily
serve them hey rich
it's
every time i every time i send one of
your tapes or videos or follows
i get these women who want to challenge
you
what ladies i have
ladies if you want to challenge me i
have a show on monday night it's 8 p.m
eastern standard time it's called the
unplugged alpha if you have a better
solution to something i've addressed
please feel free to call in and i'll put
you on and you know we can chop it up
live please you know please do but that
but that's that's why you guys crack me
up is because
you know i take on the fed i take on the
treasury i take on schools
you guys take on women you got more guts
than me
actually actually actually believe it or
not all of the the the the toughest guys
to deal with are the plugged in beta
males that are that are unwilling to
see the truth you know they just want to
keep doing what they've always done and
they always keep getting what they've
always gotten which is unfortunate
well what you guys talk about is i mean
it's not male or female it's really
about sex money power yeah when you
think about it and so a lot of times
women are now
getting more money in power
but what they lose is what you guys call
hypergamy is they get more powerful but
there's fewer men right and boy that
pisses them off yeah it's it's a tough
thing for women and you know we talk
about this for a couple minutes too but
but i was actually going to put a video
on this and we can talk about this
briefly but
you get a woman that gets about 40 years
old who's who's chased excellence all
her life she's got a bunch of degrees on
the wall framed in mahogany with little
you know
letters after her name and she's done
something with her life and she's now
become wealthy and then she looks at the
dating pool and she says all right well
let's find a guy
well women are hypergamous so that means
they date up and across that means that
she has to find somebody that's at her
level or better she's obviously going to
prefer better
and then the problem after that now is
okay so now you've shrunk the pool
dramatically
and the problem after that is a lot of
the guys that are in that age bracket
that she's looking around her age or
dating younger women and then they get
upset that they're that they're having
difficulty finding a good candidate to
you know
get into a relationship whether to start
a family with or whatever it is what it
is but uh yeah
you